so he looks for his first win of the
season
here at his first start of the season at
dodger stadium where he's been so good
throughout his career 10-3 with a 218
here what has been dominant against the
giants he's actually never faced them in
this ballpark euler to brandon belt
fly ball left field jack peterson paused
it first until he could find it now he's
there
and the ending is over so bueller finds
it after the four pitch walk to the lead
off man on the hill today for the giants
will be the right-hander kevin gausman
gosman
29 years of age he is in his seventh
year at the big league level 6
290-pounder
out of centennial colorado this is what
he has done this year owen one with a
5-2-7 era fastball struck him out
swinging
man he just he just powered that ball
right by him 97 miles an hour chewing
out a bellinger straight up stance
crowding the plate and he swings and
misses at a high fastball so guardsman
got the electric fastball going today
home of the no two pollock punches it by
bounded first and into right the dodgers
have their first base runner of the day
bueller gets him swinging sticking with
a high fast ball heinemann climbs the
ladder and comes up empty again
to alex dickerson
fastball popped up
it's been an adventure all day so far
this is an important adventure with that
runner movement and turner able to catch
it basket style waist high
to keep the game scoreless to the last
of the third
got him there's the good fastball mike's
talking about
peterson waiting for the 2-2 from
gausman here it comes fastball and he
pops it up
i say pop-up it's out in right center
field but well in the ballpark slater
over underneath it to make the catch
and that's it for the dodgers in the
third they made guzman work a little bit
there but another perfect inning for the
giants right-hander either three k's
today could really use one here second
and third one gone a 2-2 and he strikes
him out going up the ladder with a fast
ball a big second out for mueller
ostrimski can pick him up he's
walked and he's popped out
2-2 pitch
and they swing at a line drive into
center field just in front of bellinger
base hit sandoval scores racing around
third is slater here comes the throw
home and slater scores the throw is up
the third base line it's a two run
single the first hit of the game for the
giants and yastremski comes through in
the clutch two-nothing
san francisco can't lay off that curve
ball the side is retired but the giants
get the first runs of the game on a two
out base hit from jastrowski
fastball yank to right on a line for our
lead off base hit for max muncie
second base runner of the day for the
dodgers and it opens up this fifth
got him went right after him with a
fastball i mean and he just blew away a
really good fastball hitter and what set
it up
get on the ground to belt belt goes to
crawford crawford back to bell double
play make dead gauzeman
three six one on the double play and we
will head to the six it's two nothing
giant
turner goes right back through the
middle into center field to greet him
with a base hit
and the tying run is aboard in the
seventh
a 3-2 to aj pollock is lifted in the air
to left field indeed back towards the
wall he's gone
aj paddock
about pump up the volume and pump up the
volume
that changed it in the dodger dugout and
here in the stadium
slowly hit
and
that's how you lead the league and
hitting
there's a thing of beauty right there
burgers one off hernandez strokes it
down the line a fair ball into the left
field corner
smith running hard he's stopped at third
and a double from hernandez and the
dodgers in business here in the eighth
good to see hernandez hit a ball hard
and get rewarded for it
swings at the first pitch and lofts one
in the year to deep left field is
there it goes
mookie breaks it open with a three-run
shot
they go from down to enough into a head
3-2
to breathe much easier ahead 6-2
the pitch
lifted in the air down the line to right
bets over to the corner with just enough
room to end the game
the dodgers take the series with two
late home runs pollock and bets 6-2 the
final score they haven't lost a series
this year keep that up and then win
another nationally west division title
pollock the hero in this one the
go-ahead three-run shot in the bottom of
the seventh and a game where they did
nothing over the first six